よろしくお願いします
ダンマパダの四十八 八十四でしょうかね
では 説明いたします これも仏道
お釈迦様の教えは とても簡単に理解できて
実践できる方法を教えている経典一つなんですね
ナアッタヘトゥナパラッサヘトゥ
ナプッタミッチェナダナングナラッタン
ナアッタヘトゥというのは
自分のために ナパラッサヘトゥっていうのは他人のために
自分のためであろうか
人のためであろうか 次にナプッタミッチェナダナングナラッタン
プッタっていうのは息子のことで
まあだから息子という単語で
一応子供のことを一般的に意味しますね
だから子供欲しいと期待してはいけないし
ナダナン 財産欲しいとは思ってはいけないし
ラッタンというのは国ですから
国が欲しいと思うということは何か訳が分からなくなりますから
意味は権力欲しいと思うことなんですね
たとえ自分のためであっても
他人のためであっても
子孫 財産 権力を欲しがってはならないという意味なんです
全部まとめて ナイッチエイアアダンメーナサミッディマッテノ
アダンメーナっていうのは不法
不法ということでね 正しくない方法で
いわゆる悪いことをして罪を犯してサミッディマッテノ
そうやって自分の成功なんかは期待してはいけませんと
それで 生き方 こういう生き方であるべきということは説明しています
成功したいと いい加減に無責任に思うんじゃなくて
真理を犯して 罪を犯して
何も期待してはならないと
たとえ子孫であっても
財産であっても 権力であっても
その得る方法が正しくないならば
全部捨てなさいよと そういうのは期待することもダメだよと
だからナアッタヘトゥナパラッサヘトゥという言葉で
なおさらその意味を明確にするんです
例えば 自分の家族はお金がなくてもう借金して大変困っていると
で その家族を助けてあげたくなります
あるいは家族は借金払えなくてもうどうしようもない
自殺するしかないんだよと思って
家族は自殺を図っているかもしれません
そうすると 家族の一員である自分がどうしても助けてあげたいという気持ちになるんです
それはそこまででどうしようもないんですけど
だからといって 全く法を犯して
真理を犯して 道徳を犯して
絶対金を儲かるなよと
だからそれはいいわけにはならないんですね
自分の息子か誰かが借金して自殺をしたところで
自分が何かどこかお金ごまかして
とにかく借金払って子供を助けたけど
いいことをしたんだと
父親として しょうがないではないかと
父親はもう子供のことならもう何でもやるんじゃないかなということが仏教では成り立たないんです
世間 これは世間の真理なんです
世間の道徳なんですね
だからよく覚えておいてください
世間が教えて 教えていることとお釈迦様が教えてくれる言葉っていうのは
もうそんなにいつでも一致するわけじゃないんです
というか ほとんど一致しないんです
だから みんなだいたい世間が言うこと正しいと思いますね
なぜならば 大勢の人々が言ってるんだから
だから真理だよと その理屈は仏教ではないんです
だから大勢の人が完全たる智者でしょうかと
すごく苦労して まれにまれなもうまれな人間が苦労して修行してもう完全たる知恵を達したら
もうそれは一人だけなんですけど
だから一人の人が間違ってるんだっていう
大勢の人が正しいっていうことは
まあそれは世間の考え方で
仏教はそれをもう認めないんですね
客観的に見たら まあ大勢の人っていうのは無知にバカに決まってるんです
感情的で間違っているものなら大賛成するし
正しいものなら反対するし
で 例えば政治家世界を見ても
いくら国のためにまとめな経済政治対策をマニフェスト作って出しても
ネクタイの色が違います
合わないんだよということで負けるんですよ
選挙でかっこ悪いんだと
あの人は と もう可愛くないんだよと
ぐらい十分なんですよ
選挙で負けるために結構格好つけて
髪ヘアスタイルもかなりプロに頼んでヘアスタイルをして
それで服装もネクタイもかなり高価なブランドのもので
それをまたデザイナーに頼んで
もう体をもう整理してもらって
あのカメラの前でもう角度も考えて演技するならば
その人は選挙で勝ちますよ
もうあまりにも国民のことを心配してどうしようか
国のことを考えたり 計算したり
国際的なことを考えたり
それになったらこうならなくちゃいけないんだというふうな人が
もう紙はボロボロで 服はボロボロでもう暇がない
絶対勝てっこはないんですよ
追い出されます 悪人が使いされます
この人はもう国を破壊するんではないかとまで言われるんです
だからこの 人気者で一般人に売れる
バカに売れるっていうことが
世間ってのは大事なことなんです
だから何か世間世界は大騒ぎさせましたと
小泉さんが政治をやめることで
私はもう 27歳で辞めてもらった方が良かったなと思ってますけどね
で やっぱり何もできない方だったらかなり人気あるというね
で そういうのは世間の考え方なんですね
だからこの子供のことだから悪いことをしましたとかね
自分の国の時々政治家いうことなんですけど
まあ選挙でも何とかしてごまかして
不正をしてでももう自分でも偽の投票
あるいは紙を印刷してでも
それでお金払って政府の印刷機械機関がありますからね
裏で大量に印刷しても裏でもらったりもするんです
投票とかね で それにもう自分の名前に投票して
まあもう投票箱に詰め込んで
それでもまあそれはまあ勝つまでやと
勝ったら全部合法やと
選挙を管理するあの官僚の人が
あのこのこの人はまあ当選しましたと言ってサインすればもう終わり
それで最高裁判所でもこの投票は不正でしたという風にも厳しく証明しておかないと
もう無効にならないんですね
だからまあそこまでなことだからね
あと２週間だけでしょうということで
やりたい放題のことやるんですね
ある人ははっきり言ってこう言ったんで
こんなもう正しく法律に従って
そんな選挙に勝てっこはないんだよと
ということでも この決まって不正的なことをやるのは合法的で
合法的にやるのは不正的で負ける道でという風になっているところまでなんですね
世間の状況は だから 方法はどうであっても
たくさん金儲けたら金持ちではないかと
それから誰も文句言わないでしょうと
ということで 例えばこのクーデターとかなんとかやったりしてね
かなり汚いことをやったりと
パキスタンやらね マレーシアとかね
もう信じられないぐらい酷いことをやって
もう政権を取ったり 政権を取ってから自分が大統領だから
まあそれからもう合法的にやると
マレーシアなんかはこの政府が不正的なことをやってるんだということを言っただけで
この野党の人にもう何か強引に無理に何かいろいろ訴えて裁判かけて
もう牢屋に入れて もう選挙に出る資格もないと
そこまでやらせたりするんです
だから 同じ人も２回裁判にかける羽目になっちゃったんですね
マレーシアで で １回同じ訴えなんで １
回は全く無罪だと もう捨てられちゃったんだけど
まだ同じことで また別にいろいろ人を頼んで
お前証言してねとか 証言しなさいと
だから  もう何としてでも自分の権力を守るとかね
で それから自分の親戚のために政治やってるんだと
だから親戚がとことん儲けなくちゃいけないと
何が悪いんですかという感じなんですね
で 世間はそういう生き方は正しいとね
認めているんです で かなり悪いことをしなきゃ
この世間ではこの 認めないんですね
しかし お釈迦様が言うのは
たとえ子供のことであろうがなんだ
自分の成功はね 不正的にはもう認めない
不正的には求めない 真理
こちらで不正っていうのは悪を犯すことなんですね
だからこの国の法律のことではありません
で で 法律と道徳はいつでも一緒になるわけじゃないんです
で 例えばアメリカではね
共産主義的な思考を持っただけで法律違反で逮捕されるんです
しかし 人間何考えててもいいんじゃないかっていうのは普通なんですけど
なんで考えるところまで法律で厳しくもう違法とするのかと
そういうことをしながら
他の国々では自由がないことにはぐちゃぐちゃいろんなことを言うんです
だからまあ言いたいのは
この法律守ったんだからといって道徳を守ったことになりません
法律も結局は非道徳的で
もう自分の利益のために作るものはものすごいたくさんですよ
例えばこの違法的にね
インサイダー取引やらね
もうごまかしの証券運営やらで
価値もないのにわざわざと価値をつけたりしてね
証券売ったり売買されたりして
それでものすごいもう損をすると
これは明らかに 違法で強盗なんですけど
それはまあ リーマン・ブラザーズみたいなものすごい大会社がやるならば
それは合法的なんですね
そうなってくると もう国のお金はいくらでも出して助けてあげる
しかし ある個人がちょこちょこと情報を取って株を買ったならば
もうもう五年監牢屋に入れるという
悪いことをしましたと
それはもう五千万円をちょっと違法的に儲かったら大変な罪で
五兆円だったら合法的なんですね
五百兆円だったら もう明らかにもう
もう世界救わなくちゃいけないという態度で
もうもうもう世界は狂いますから
もうアメリカ政府が  FBI がものすごい真剣に税金を今注ぎ込むという
ということになっているんですね
ありがたいことですね
私を助けてくれてるんだから
一応世界っていうのはそういうもので
だから世間世界考える法律は道徳ということにはならない
そこら辺はかなり中道的に物事を考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
何でもかんでも法律に逆らうことが正しいというわけじゃないんです
で 罪になる悪 悪行為も法律で禁じているし
だから法律は完璧だというのは
それはありえないんです
法律の一部は悪行為をも戒めているし
個人は個人で人を殺してはならないんです
組織で殺すのはいいんです
そういうところで 組織で殺したっていうのも殺しなんですけど
個人で個人を殺したらもう殺人なんですね
だからとにかく殺してはならないというところは
まあ悪く道徳でもあります
そういうところですから
かなり分析して物事を判断しなくちゃいけないんですから
一つも断言的に言うのは難しい
いつでも分析して 良いところ取って悪いところ捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
ふるいにかけなくちゃいけないんです
いつでも世の中のことは
ふるいにかけて物事を判断しなくちゃいけないんです
で こちらでこのお釈迦様がおっしゃっている真理に
簡単に軽く達する方法なんです
で ある人 ある人がいる
その人は人間だから まあ成功はしたいんですね
成功したいというところまでは
まあ自然の流れで それで
俗世間の立場から見ると
成功するということは
まあ子孫がいること 家族がいること
子供がいれば その点で成功しています
で 財産もあったら もうかなり成功しています
で また権力のある人だったら
なおさら成功しているんです
だから 子孫 財産 権力というもう三段階で
俗世間は成功というものは判断するんですね
それはただ目に見えるもので
で それは別のお釈迦様は否定しないで
見事の真理を語る これ中道っていうのは
ものすごい面白い そういうわけなんです
真ん中を語ってるんじゃないんです
正しい世界を出してるんです
だから 子孫 財産 権力を身につけることは成功でしょうっていうことには
イエスともノーとも何も言わないんです
言わないで罪を犯して決して得たくないって思う人は
そんなのは欲しいんだけど
罪を犯しては絶対嫌だと
思うならば その人は道徳を完了しているんです
サシーラは戒律のある人っていうのはその人のことでした
さ パンニャは？智慧のある人っていうのはその人のことであると
ダンミコ ブッダの真理を身につけている人
真理に達した人っていうのは
その人のことであると
そこで理解簡単だと思いますよ
私たち 私たちの心の中で
無意識的にも気持ち的にも
それは嫌やと もうやりたくはないと
というか もうもうそんなことはもうやらない
とにかく たとえ自分の子供やらお子さんやら誰死にかけていても
もうなんとか悪いことでもしなきゃ
もうもうもう助け もう死ぬぞと思ったっても
やっぱり自分のお子さんにもう死にかけて
それ守る 助けてあげるためには悪いことする
それはやめる 例えば腎臓移植しなくちゃいけない
もう本当に血液が通う人知っていて
もう大した人間じゃないと
なんか愛想を殺しちゃえば
もうもう 腎臓取られるんではないかとかね
そういうことっていうのは絶対やらないんですね
そこはちょっと恐ろしいかもしれませんだけど
インドでは簡単にやってるんですよ
中東の連中ももうもうそういう贅沢しすぎだからね
置きなんかそこ行かれます
そうするともう人を誘拐して
なんでもしてにももういくらでもお金あるんだからね
自分の命だけ守る だからイスラム教でなければ人間じゃなくて
ただの生き物だからね
獣と同じですから 扱いは
だからこの そういう恐ろしいことって世の中でよくあることなんです
それで道徳の人 戒律完成している人
知恵のある人っていうのは
微塵も 罪を犯して何も得ようとしないという
で わかりやすく言えば
自分が死ぬのは まあそれはしょうがない
家族からそれはもうどうしようもない
もう もう合法的には助けることはできないんだと
罪を犯さず助けてあげることはできないんだよ
だからこの それぐらいの気持ちでいることなんですね
そこでこの家族を死なせても
自分が金がなくて もう飢え死になってもいいでしょうか？という話じゃないんです
もう食べ物がなくてなくて
もう飢え死にになろうとも死にかけていて
もう何か物を取って食べたってしょうがないでしょうというのは我々なんです
しかし そういう生き方は正しくないんです
自分が飢えていても 店の前でいろいろ食べ物やら果物やら
もうもう道路にもう違法的に置いて置いているでしょう
いろんな店ではね 本当はあれも法律違反ですよ
店の外に出してますから
人が歩くところに だから雨が降ったりするとさっさと中に入れなくちゃいけないし
それでもう区役所の人々が来てももう何も言えませんね
別にテントを張って固定したところじゃないんだから
ちょっと置いただけで物を置くなよと言えませんだからね
例えば人が歩くところで我々のカバンが置いたっても
これはお主やと言えませんよ
しかし アルミね そこで置いておいたらダメなんです
人々は歩くところだから
抱えでカバンを置いたんだからといって
誰かが来てあんた間違ってる
罰金がということもできないんです
そこは使っても前に果物やらいろんなものもう山積みにして
これぐらいこれぐらい値段やとか
安くるものは一番目に入るとこもし全くもう上上になってる人だったら
日本だったら物取り食べるのはとても簡単なんですね
店にも一人しか あるいはせいぜい二人しかいないし
お客さんはもう結構人さんも来るし
だからそんなに目がいくわけないし
品物一つ一つ持っていっても
もうどうしようもないということはないんですね
気付かず取っていうことはいくらでもできます
しかし 仏教というのは
いくらなんでも自分がもうあと一日で何も食べなかったら死ぬんだよと言ったっても
もう罪を犯してはならないんだと
そういうことは死ぬことを正当化しているかというと
それは何のこと仏教は心配しないんです
なぜならば 罪を犯さない人間は
それよりもっと死んだということは一回一回もないんです
人間は幸福で生きていられます
これをおかしくしているのは
人間のこの屁理屈な思考のせいであって
真理のせいじゃないんです
ブッダの教えのせいじゃないんです
自分たちがまるっきり考え方はおかしいでしょうに
だから ここまで人類の九十九パーセントというか九十もう九九九九九九パーセントぐらいみんな間違って変に不幸になる思考で生きてて
こんな程度ででも生きているんだから
真理を守って生きるということは
そうそう別すぐ幸福な道になるはずなんです
今考える数字とはずいぶん違う数字になります
だから人間というのは
真理を守る人は真理に守られる
この真理に守られる人を倒産させることっていうのは
逮捕させるっていうことか
誰にもできない いくら国家権力があっても
真理を守る人にとってはもう指一本触れることできないんです
すごい力強いんです その人の財産はなくならないんです
だから死ぬ羽目になりません
不幸になる羽目になります
しかし 私たちは本当かなというブッダの教えを疑うんですね
やっぱりそれはそんなこと言ったっても
やっぱりもう凶暴でなきゃ
この世の中で生活できないんだと
それでただもう半信半疑で
本当は内心的には認めてないんだけど
試してみて ちょっと道徳守るというこのいい加減に試したりすると
これは負けます 本心じゃないんだからね
じゃあ私は嘘を言わないことのしよう
本当は嘘嘘をつかないという決定になってないんです
それで決定になってないんだから
もうダメになっちゃいます
しかし 心がもう真理に従って生活するぞということは決
手になったらもう何のこともできない
その人はものすごい強い人になるんです
だから業っていうのは物理法則と同じことで
もう変えることできないんですよ
だから科学的には物質しか知らないんでしょうし
だから科学者が物質の法則はそれなりに発見してあるし
例えばピカピカ光ったんだから出てもう黄色い色で金にはならないんですね
で なぜならば科学者は金ならもうもうこれぐらい重さがあり
例えば 1 何て言いますか
もう 1 センチの 3 は何て言いますか
1 リップ  1 立方センチメートルセンチメートルの金ならこれぐらいグラムは重いんだろうと
ことははっきり決まってるんだから
それで他の金属はね もう 2 ミリ 3 ミリ金を張っておいても
それでなんとか酸に入れてみたっても溶けたりもしない
あ なるほど金やと これはできないんですよ
ごまかすことは だから物質の法則も私たちに好き勝手に変えることはできません
例えばアルケミーみたいに金属を金に変えるということは
これはもう法則的に不可能なんです
これは原子の世界で変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
金の原子にあのエレクトロンどれぐらい付いてるのかってこと決まってるんだから
それだったら核の重さは変えなくちゃいけないんですね
これは不可能ですね だからアルミを金にしてやろうと思ったっても
これはもう不可能ということになってるんです
それっていうのは法則と言えば法則なんですね
金属のいろいろたくさん金属あるのは何なのかというと
もうそれは科学者がちゃんと調べて調べて説明してあるんです
で そのようにそれ我々には変えることできない
何か変えるならば それなりのいろいろ工夫するだけなんですね
それと同時に 心のことも同じで
法則的に いわゆる心の働きを見れば
法則の発見はできます
物質を調べたら物質の法則を発見できたようなことで
心を調べてみれば 心の法則も発見できますね
それで それは誰にも変えることできません
地球はあるわけがあって
自転公転しています それは法則になるんですね
それで科学的には そこで法則というものを発見して
これでこれでこうやって
このスピードで自転していて
このスピードで公転しているんだと
それは変えることできないんです
で 私たちは何かするならば
その法則に従って何かするしかないんです
宇宙に行きたいんだからって好き勝手にはいけません
その法則の中から法則に従って宇宙に行けるんです
法則を破っているわけじゃないんです
地球にあるものはもう地球から離れませんよ
それは決まりだと それはわかるんです
決まりです なぜかと それからその法則に従って何とか何とか工夫して宇宙に出ることはできるようになるんですね
しかし 宇宙に出たんだからで
地球の法則を破ったわけじゃないんで
打ち勝ったぞということにもま
なれないんですね  心にも法則がありまして
生きるということは心のことであって
だから心の法則の中から出てきたものなんですよ
業論というのは 心が幸福
不幸を感じる法則 そこをわかりやすくもう殺生したり
盗んだり よくない行為をしたりすると
心はかなりダメージ受けますよと
理由はただ自分のことしか考えないという自我意識がそう罪を重ねするんですよ
自我意識でエゴイストで己のこと以外何も考えないという
己のことを考えると心が内向きになってどんどん壊れていくんですね
エネルギーが エネルギーが壊れていくと
もう不幸になってしまうんですね
これはもう誰にもどうすることもできないんです
じゃあ心を強くして幸福になりたければ
自我意識を捨てることなんですね
で エゴの気持ちを薄くなればなるほど
心はすごく強くなるんです
だから強い心は幸福になるに決まっている
だからそれは誰にもどうすることもできるものじゃないんです
お釈迦様にもどうすることもできないんです
法則を教えてあげるしかできません
そういうことだから 真理を守ることで
罪を犯さないことで 人が不幸になるということは絶対ありえないことで
断言的に罪を犯さない人が幸福になるんです
しかし 世間は全く反対のことを言っているんです
とにかく人間の成功というのは
子孫 財産 権力があることであると
お釈迦様はそれにはニコッとして
あのね 健康であることは一番幸福であると
どう見ても健康でなければ
子孫がいたって財産があったって権力があったっても全然意味がないんだから
一番得というのは健康でいることですと
財産 サントゥッティ・パラマンだなぁ
喜びがあること 最高の宝物やと
喜び 充実感 だから心で判断するんですね
なんで子孫がいれば幸福は成功やっていうかというと
子孫がいることで本人が充実感
喜びを感じているんですよ
子孫がいても奥さんのことでクタクタ悩んで苦しんでいるならば
子供のことでむちゃくちゃ苦しんでいるならば
幸福は感じませんよ だから子供がいたんだからといって人は幸せわけじゃないんです
子供がいる それで喜びを感じるならば
その人は幸せなんですよ
ですから 結局は充実感が最高な財産であると
財産ではないんだ 充実感なんですね
財産は  それで仏道を完成して悟りに達する場合はどうすればいいかということは
ここで別な角度でわかりやすく言っているんです
成功したいという気持ちがあっても
心の中でもう断定しているんです
罪は犯しませんよと 幸福になる
成功したいという気持ちを捨てる必要はないんです
罪だけは犯しません 犯しませんと
そういう心が決定的になる
最初はもう無理にでも決定しておくんですよ
それで少々時間経つと
これが心の本来の性格になっているんです
もうその人はもうかなり解脱へ進んでいるんです
それ進めば必ず最終的に悟りに解脱に達する
これはもう間違いなし
決定的 だから最初にそこを決めておけば
それだけで自動的にもう解脱まで進んでいくんです
だから何 すれば 人はものすごく簡単に解脱へ自動的に進むのかというと
この答えがこの 84番目で教えているんです
罪だけは犯さない それだけなんですよ
別に何か変なことをやっているわけじゃないんです
罪だけは犯さない ただそれだけ
普通に生きてるんです
だから必ず普通に生きている必要もあるんですよ
どこか隠れていても それはちょっとわからないんです
それは仏教は完璧ということで
普通に生きる必要もあります
普通の社会で 普通の社会人で
生活しなくちゃいけないんです
生活しながら罪を犯せません
全く微塵も ではどうするのかと
それで本人がする道が修行にあるんです
だから自動的に解脱へ進んでいくんです
そんな時間かかるものじゃないんですよ
かなり早く解脱に達することはできます
子供の面倒を見るし 奥さんの機嫌も取るし
会社にも行くし 仕事もするし
友達の関係もそのまま持っていくし
一つもやめることはしません
ちょっと一つだけ変えるんです
心の中で何があっても罪は犯しません
信条は破れませんと ただそれだけで人は解脱まで達するんだということです
先生 この今の偈の説明ですと
この 1行目の「ナアッタヘトゥ」というところの次が 3行目に行って
3行目の成功ということですか
それは成功というものの説明が
2行目の子供と財産と国
順番に 2行目から読んでいくと
子供とか財産とか国を欲しないっていう
欲することには要するに意味がないというか
理由がないという  切っちゃうとそうなるんです
しかし この 4行の偈っていうのは
釈迦に説かれた場合はちゃんとした論理構成があるんです
私は論理学も忘れちゃったんだから
これはちゃんともう普通誰でも思うことを言って
その理由を言って その問題点を示して答えを出すというシステムなんですね
だから なぜだからというふうなものを入れなくちゃいけないんです
だから この切れる場合は明確に切ることできるんです
そこはもう 4行目一緒に切れないんです
例えば「ナアッテナパラッセヘトゥ」というのは自分のため
他人のため そこは何かというと
人間っていうのは何かを行う場合は
自分のためか他人のために行うんですね
しかし この他人というのは他の他人のために何かやるわけじゃないんです
家族のためなんです この献身的になるのも
自分が危険なことでももう平気でやるのも
結局は家族のためなんですね
そういうことで自分がよく頑張ってるんだという成功感が出てくるんですね
それで具体的に何やというと
子孫 財産 権力ということになるんですね
だからあまりにも具体的に明確に派手に言ってるだけなんです
だから子孫 財産 権力っていうのは自分のためでありながら
他人のためでもある じゃあある人が国民みんな幸せにしてやろうと思っちゃうと
もう権力を握らなくちゃいけないんでしょ
それだったら権力はないと何もできんだから
あるいは有名にならなくちゃいけないんだと
有名になったら言うことをみんな聞くという
だからこれはもうどうしようもないんです
有名になるというと 自分のためにやっていることになっちゃうしね
自分が有名になるんだから
なんで私が有名になったのか
いえ たくさん活動したかったということになるんです
だから 1行  2行で状況を説明する
それをまとめてサミッディという言葉にするんです
成功 成功 成長ということにする
一行二行の意味はサミッディという一言葉にまとめて
それはアダンメイの法を破っては期待するなかれと
だからイッジェイヨ イッジェと同じ動詞使ってるんです
それから結論をつけるんです
その人がシーラワーであってパンニャワーであってダンミコーであると
一行一行二行だけ独立させちゃうと
なんか恐ろしい考えになっちゃうんですよ
自分のためにも 他人のためにも
子供を期待するなよと
財産期待するなよと 権力を期待するなよと
そうすると反社会的な考え方になっちゃうんですね
例えばナプッタミッジェナダナンナラッタンという行だけ我々吟송する
どうなるんですかね なんか自分書く文章に何かにナプッタミッジェナダナンナラッタン
お釈迦様に言われているんだよと
ナプッタミッジェ子供を期待もう希望するなかれ
ナダラン 財産希望するなかれ
何の権力も希望するな
ラッタンというのは国だから国にも国も希望するなかれ
どういうことですかね
そうです 全く反社会的
反人間的な言葉になっちゃうんです
これなぜならばとかね
なぜでしょうかというものはないと
しかし 三行目は釈尊の結論なんですね
論理を立てて 人間は成功とこういうものはするんだよと
それは一般的に あの 何と言いますか
プロポシス プロポプロポジションじゃないんですね
これリダクション リダクティブロジックですから
リダクション リダもうリダクション
インダクション 両方お釈迦様は一緒に使いますから難しいんです
これもうもうもう随分もうもう忘れてました
こんなのあまり良くないしね
論理語るのは でも論理学の中ではそういうところは一応説明してやるような気がしますよ
もう今更ダルマキティさんのテキストは読みたくはないし
ブディストロジックというものはね
もう発展してますからね
ネッティッパカラナというテーラワーダでもテキストあるんですよ
お釈迦様のネッティっていうのは医療
このロジカルポジションですね
それはどうやって持ってくるのかというね
そちらはソーラサハラねといって十六の方法で結論に達するということがありましてね
ものすごくそういうところになってくると難しいね
単純なロジックだからね
とにかく三行目はお釈迦様がこれこれであって
これこれでの上でこうこうなってるんであって
ですからこれこれですというもう結論を出すんです
で 結論はね イッチェイヤ アダンメーナ サミッディ マッテノー
それがお釈迦様が言いたかった行だから
それが引用できるんですよ
独立させて それブッダが決めた自分の知恵で決めた行なんです
それを独立させてどこでも引用できます
アダンメーナ サミッディ ないっちぇっていう
違法的に成功は期待するなかれと
成功は違法で得るものではありませんと
それはいくらでもカラクリできますよ
違法で得るものは成功ではありませんと
俗世間的に見られる成功でも
違法で得たならば それはもう不成功であるとかね
どんな風にでも変えることはできます
どういう風に変えたっても
言葉はしっかりしています
ガタガタにならない それはブッダの言葉の故なんです
三行目だけ しかし 四行目はどうしようかというと
それは別な結論だから
その人は道徳者でありていたっても
誰でしょうかと やっぱり三行目の人なんです
議論 疑問は何ですかね
ですから その一行目二行目で
今先生がおっしゃったように
一行目二行目だけを見ると結構激しい反社会的なというか
という感じがしたので
その三行目四行目とのつながりがどういうふうに構成されているのかなというのがちょっと気になってました
先生は一行目と三行目
後で二行目を説明した感じだったので
それだと分かりやすかった
サミッディンというのの言葉の解説は二行目ですからね
まあこの行はもうどう見たっても社会の考え方ではないんだからね
だから世間の思考とは違いますけど
決して反社会的 反人間的というわけじゃないんです
これは人間の社会の幸福を考えたんだからこそ言っている言葉なんです
すいません この二行目っていうのが
子供を財産を望まないっていうのが
アダンメーナ望まないということなんです
在家というよりは 出家の方に説かれたっていう
いえいえ それはそんな関係ないんです
そうすると仏説は不完全な教えになるんです
出家には適していますけど
在家には適していないんだ
そんなのお釈迦様は教えません
完全にかたるということは
どこを見たに完全なんです
財産子孫望むなかれというのは
違法で望むなかれと 自分にお坊さんが欲しいんだから人を結婚している奥さんを強引に家に連れてくるんじゃないんです
それはやめなさいと 合法的に結婚したければ合法的に結婚しなさいと
お金が欲しいんだからといって強盗するんじゃないんです
コンビニに夜行って お金が欲しければ合法的にやりなさいと
出家の場合はだから欲を捨てるということがありまして
生きるために出家するんじゃないんですよ
生計を立てるために出家するんじゃない
そちらはよく誤解があるんですよ
みんななんか自分の生計は在家で立てられるので
私は出家したい 出家したいとかね
冗談じゃないんです それから気楽で生きていたいと
それは恐ろしいんです
気楽かもうそんなのは考えたことじゃなくて
生きるために出家するんじゃないんです
解脱をするために出家するんですよ
だから まあ商売に手を出したりとかね
ことは成り立たない 障害に何で手を出すのかというと
生きるためでしょう 生きるために出家したんじゃないんだから
解脱するために出家するんだから
障害に手を出してはならんということで
採算も禁止でしょうし
子孫も禁止でしょうし
そんなのはその論理で自動的にもう当たり前に成り立つもので
出家はするべきというところははっきりと比丘はと釈迦様は主語を入れるんです
しかし 比丘はと主語を入れても
内容はみんなに通じるという
例えば 出家がお布施もらいたく
信者さんの機嫌を取るような言葉をしゃべると
気に障ること言わないで
すごく褒め称えたりして
ああ いいですね 本当に優しい人ですね
あれやこれやとかね 褒めたり
ものすごくすごい大きい声で挨拶したり
あれこれやと もう謙虚に振り回ったりすると
最近の人はいいお坊さんがとすぐ喜んじゃってお布施したりする
これは法律違反で戒律違反なんです
ではそれは出家の世界でしょ
では在家どうですか？同じことなんです
いろいろ利益を得たいために丁寧に挨拶するとかね
とんでもないんです 挨拶は相手を認めるために
相手の尊厳を認めるためにやるものであって
デパートでなんかロボットみたいな訓練させちゃって
これぐらいの角度で こういう風に体を曲げて笑う時はこれぐらいは口を開けてとか
もう訓練させるっていうことは
これは単純な強盗なんですね
だからそういうことをやる人々は仕事で疲れるでしょう
一睡もたまるでしょう
失敗もするでしょう あれぐらい訓練させているのに
だからそれは強盗する方を教えているんだから悪であって
悪の結果みんな得ているんです
ではなく 道徳っていうのは人間同士でみんな平等でしょうに
みんなに尊厳あるでしょうに
そこは認めることは慈しみの行為であって
こんにちはということは
お元気ですか？ということは
お元気ですか？元気でいてほしいという気持ちで
それだったらそれは善行為であって
それによって ではうちの品物を買ってくださいと
それは強盗であって そういうことで人の機嫌取るなよと
お布施のために これは戒律で項目で禁止していますが
それは出家のことだから
我々はどうしようもないっていうことになりません
我々 人の機嫌を取っておかなきゃ商売はもううまくいかないんだよと言ってやってはいるんですけど
それでやってみてくださいと
あんた方はすごいストレス溜まっちゃうんだよと
朝から晩まで頭を苦労して考えなきゃうまくいかないんだよと
それだったら ちょっとしたことで倒産になるんだよと
だから人の機嫌取ったり
挨拶したり 人間関係を美しく持つのは慈しみの行為であって
生命の尊厳を認めることであってっていうことで
やる人の場合はそんなことは何のこともないんです
そういうことやと思います
あの 一応あの それよりはこれすごい論理的な考え方で
あの 仏教を実践するっていうことは
ある特別な宗教を信仰していることじゃないんです
これ そういう科学的な生き方なんです
自然法則の中で生きていることだけなんですよ
例えば 結婚は教会でやらなくちゃいけないとかね
どこで教会に人を結婚させる権利が入ったんですかね
これ 自然の流れで人間は結婚するっていうことになっただけでしょうに
もし人間にも動物と同じく
メスには勝手に子育てできるならば
結婚っていうのは成り立たないんです
しかし 鳥たちの間でヒナがままりは食べる
もう体重の3倍一日で食べるんだから
これで母鳥がどうやって餌取るのかというと
もうそんな自分でもお腹いっぱい食べることもできないし
自分一人だけでも その場合は見事に夫婦なんですね
鳥たちは それで雄鳥も雌鳥ももう大体です
もう餌を持ってくるわ来るわ来るわ
もうキリがない 私は一つ観察したところで
このもう 雄鳥は 雄鳥はもうものすごい速いスピード
もう体力もあるんだから
さっさと飛んでて何か取ってくるんです
取ってきてパクパクと口にさせてまた出ていく
また持ってきて また だから計算したんですよ
あの回ぐらい 雄鳥はもうオスは持ってくる餌は回に
メスの鳥は母親が回ぐらいですね
やっぱり行ってあっちこっち見て
もう一つもう取ると あ
イスはもう回も取ってるんですから
で 持ってきてもう刺すんですね
しかし その代わりにすぐ整理整頓するんですね
もう丁寧に食べさせて
あのフンとかも外へ出して
ちょっと周りを見て また飛んでいくんです
そんなことやってると
もうヒナが飢えちゃって死んじゃいますから
もう男の方はもうバンバン持ってくる
とにかく それで夫婦が仲良く子育てするんですよ
別にそういう風に この自然の流れで現象が自動的に現れるので
神が定めるんじゃないんです
で 交尾だけして全く関係なく出て行く鳥たちもいます
その場合はもう母はもう全部面倒見ることができるんです
だから人間結婚するっていうことは同じことで
一人では子育てできません
だから結婚ということになっているんです
ただそれだけのことで
それが神様が決めてくれなきゃダメだとかね
まあおかしいんですね
その思考は 教会で結婚しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そういう変なことをさせるっていうことは宗教であって
仏教はもう何一つも変なことをさせる
変なことさせた時点で変でしょうに
因果法則というのはそういうことなんです
何一つも変は変です 変はありえないんです
偶然っていうのは全く絶対ありえないんです
我々平気で偶然偶然って言うでしょう
これ私たちの愚かさを表現しているんです
自分には説明できなかっただけの話なんです
自分が期待しなかっただけなんです
この間偶然友達に会ったって何考えてるんですか？友達に会う予定がなかっただけの話です
ということで 偶然っていうのはありえないし
変というものもありえないし
普通の流れなんです だから流れを変えることっていうのはできないんです
やってもいけないんです
流れを変えちゃうと ものすどんな結果になるかっていうことは
もう因果法則を知らない人は知ったものじゃないんです
だから 科学的な世界がかなり地球にダメージ与えるんですね
次どうなるかということを気にしないで何かやってみると
やることはすべて変なもんでしょうに
自然にないものをいろいろ組み立てて組み立てて
どんなことになるのかと調べるんです
そうすると大変なことになるんです
それでお釈迦様の教えでは
そういう何か変なことをさせるんじゃなくて
そのまま因果法則の流れの中で成長して解脱に達するという
だから この 4行目の言葉がね
強調しているのは 特別に何もやる必要ないんです
特別にやること何にもない
ただ人間なら成功したいと思っている
それただそれだけ それも自然ですから
やめなさいよと 言ったっても不可能でしょうに
人は成功したいと思っているんだから
その通りやめなさいとやめさせたら
その人は成功する気持ちをやめたことが成功だと思っているんだから意味がないんです
じゃあ私は勉強することもやめた
仕事をすることもやめたと
だからお金ないんだからもうホームレスになってやったと
だから成功して 私は成功は全て捨てましたと
言って それが成功なの
そのバカにとっては だから成功する気持ちはこれは取り消せないんです
だからそれは放っておいて
心の法則は誰も知りませんだからね
それはブッダしか知らないんだからね
そちらの中でも法則破らないでくださいと
それだけ だから真理 ダンマ
ダンマというのはそのわけなんです
真理 法則 それは普通我々仏教の中で解説するときは善悪にしますけど
お釈迦様が善悪というところではなくて
真理という言葉を使っているんです
真理の場合は心の法則は
それもまた真理ですからね
それも犯すなよと だから成功は成功で
そうするともう本当にしっかりと成功しますよと
だから成功するために子供を捨てたとかは成り立たないんです
このストーリーはだいたいストーリーと偈は合わないんですから
これを私 私には解決できない問題で
ダンマパダった方に 注釈書にはちょっと物語をいつでもつけているんです
だから経典の場合は どこでなぜ語ったのかという
は いつでも経典の中にはだいたい入ってますね
入ってない経典もあります
スッタニパータの経典とかは
ワンメースタン このように私は聞きまたお釈迦様は祇園精舎に住んでおられる時があった
そのセクションはないんですね
ただ言葉だけで その場合は後からこれに何か因縁物語を作らなくちゃいけないということがあって作ったりする
それはあったり 合わなかったり
ダンマパダの偈っていうのは
おそらくお坊さんたち
誰にでも暗記 覚えて 喋る時
考える時 日常生活で使うための金言というかね
そういうものなんですね
だからお釈迦様の言葉だけみんな覚えていて
これはいつ どの どこで
何のために最初に説かれたということもうないんだから
それにエピソードを作ってあげようと
ずいぶん後で 注釈書の時代でものすごく頑張ってエピソードをつけてつけてつけてつけてつけていくんですよ
それでもうあったり合わなかったり
何かストーリーを作ったんだからといって
だからあんまり私はこれちょっとストーリーは使わないんです
こちらにあるストーリーもある人が奥さんとずいぶん仲良くいて
もうお互いもうよく喋っているんだと
いろいろくだらん世間話とか
夫婦で それでこの人が仏教徒だから
実は私は出家したいと思ってますよと
そしたら奥さんがまあ奥さんは仏教徒で反対じゃないんですね
でもまあ子供がお腹にいるんだからね
ということで ああ そういえばそうだなと
男もまあじゃあ子供生まれるまでっていうのに待っていて
生まれたらまだお互い仲がいいんだから
どうでしょうかね 子供が生まれたことで
でも私は出家したいと思っているんだよと
奥さんも旦那さんの夢を叶えてあげたいんだけど
でもまだ子供が小さいんだからね
ちょっと歩けるところまで
そういうことで まあ子供はなんかよちよち歩けるようになったら
まだ旦那さんが自分の夢を出しちゃうと
やっぱり子供はもうちょっと大きくなるまでとかなるんですね
それで結婚するまで 男は考えて
それで結婚するまで で
孫が生まれるまでとか
どこまで待つんでしょうかと
言ってももうもうもうもうこれはどこまでいくら待ってもまだまだあるんだから
どこかで切れなくちゃいけないということで出家するんです
で 出家して修行して悟りに達する
悟りに達したところで
自分の子供はもうそれなりに大きくなってから出て行ったんだからね
子供はなんで父親が家を出て行ったんでしょうかとかね
喧嘩していても いい喧嘩したわけでもなく
夫婦はすごく仲が良くて
もう何の問題もなく それでも出家したんだから
仲良い夫婦なのに 母親のことを嫌で
あるいはもう自分が不倫して追い出されたとかじゃ何もないんですね
そしたら息子は不思議でね
あれ なんででしょうかと
言って喋ってみたら 本人も仏教に目覚めて
本人も出家して悟りに達するんです
そうすると奥さんが私はずっともう家を守ったのを守ったのはこの二人のためだと
二人も出ていたら なんで私は家にいるんで
私も出家すると三人とも出家して三人とも悟りに達したという話なんです
だから誰も不幸になってないんです
三人とも人生を成功したんです
それとこの偈はどういうふうに合わせるのかっていうことは
ちょっと私にはできません
無理です だったらストーリーをもっと派手に書いた方が良かったんですよ
あの男はものすごいもうところ構わず奥さんを愛して
もう家族のために頑張っていたんだとかね
それでもうやがて諦めて
なんで罪を犯してまであの家族を養わなくちゃいけないと思って諦めて出家したんだと
それで奥様も同じことをやって
子育てにもうところ構わず頑張ったところで
もう子供がもう大人になって家出したところで
何やっていたんでしょう
私はと 何の意味じゃないんではないかと
で 出家したんだとかね
それで息子もあれほど苦労して育てたのに
私はこんな悪い生活をしてね
意味がないんだと 成功したってもと悪いこと言って出家したんだと
ストーリーだったら何とか合いますけど
そうはないんですね だからまあわからないんです
まあ大体ストーリーはたまに関係ある場合ありますよ
その場合は 経典の中でもストーリーと偈繋げてるんです
あの大体経典にもいろんなところで同じ偈見つかりますから
で その場合はもうエピソード
因縁 セクションも入ってますからね
それもぴったし合ってます
例えばこのコーサラサンユットサンユッタニカーナのね
コーサラサンユッタというところのセクションがあります
コーサラ王様との対話が起きたところで
で で 王様たちがね 乗った乗り物っていうのは派手な乗り物だから
それそのまま保管してあるんですね
父親が乗っていた馬車はもう息子は新しい車作る
馬車作るんだから それはもう捨てるわけにいきませんしね
いろんな装飾品がつけたりあって
銀で飾ってあったりとかね
で それを大事にしておいて
それでもうおじい様のものもあったりする
それで奥様たちのお妃たちの乗った車もあって
それ全部ザーッとありまして
そこでお釈迦様と一緒に見て
ちょっと見て歩いたところで
全部ボロボロになってますね
使ってはないものはもう
もう何て言いますか 古くなって古くなって
もう使い物にならないんですね
それでお釈迦様はいくら手を込んでね
ものすごい真剣に王様乗る車だからしっかりしたものですよ
そういうものを作ったっても
これは壊れていきますよと
それと同時に体も同じだよと
壊れていくんだよと ジーダンテヴィーラージュサタなんとかアトーサヴェーランピジャランウペティ
それだけじゃなくて この体もみるみるうちに老いていくんだよと
だから真理の道は歩むしかないんだよという風に偈を
してあげて それはぴったしストーリーと合うんです
そのストーリーは一応経典の中にあるんだから大丈夫ですけど
大体こちらではもうないものは強引に入れちゃいます
何かストーリー繋げるんです
はい 一応その偈の意味はそれぐらいで終了いたします